You want to see what kind of hole you will leave when you leave this company? Put your hand in a bucket of water and pull it back out and look in the bucket. That's the hole you will leave when you exit. You are replaceable. And the lead on New Colonel walked up to this EP and handed him his badge and walked out the door. So I would attend the wedding just to hear that. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 139, recorded on June 29th, 2023. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we finish out our conversation with Sean Parent live from C++ on C2023. This is part three of a three-part conversation.
你想看看当你离开这家公司时会留下什么样的空缺吗？把手伸进一桶水里，然后再抽出来，看看桶里。这就是你离开时留下的空缺。你是可替代的。而新内核项目的负责人走到这位副总裁面前，把胸牌交给他，然后走出了大门。所以我会为了听到这句话而去参加婚礼。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客，我是康纳，今天是 2023 年 6 月 29 日，我和我的联席主持布莱斯一起，在 C++ on Sea 2023 现场完成了与肖恩·帕特的对话。这是三部分对话的第三部分。
If you haven't listened to the first two, links will be at the top of the show notes. In this conversation, we chat about a plethora of things, but mostly why Sean Parent left Apple to join Adobe. Yeah, I've been super fortunate in my career in that I've had the opportunity to do a number of successful products. And when I look back, it's like I worked on the transition to PowerPC at Apple. And we were a small team, less than a dozen engineers on the team. And the company was betting big on a partnership with Novell to move to Intel
如果你还没有听过前两部分，链接会放在节目笔记的最上方。在这次对话中，我们聊了很多事情，但主要是关于肖恩·帕特为什么要离开苹果加入 Adobe。是的，在我的职业生涯中，我非常幸运，有机会参与了许多成功的产品。回顾过去，我参与了苹果向 PowerPC 的过渡。我们当时是一个小团队，不到十几名工程师。当时公司正大举押注与 Novell 的合作，转向英特尔
at the time. And that team had like 200 people. And we smoked them. Okay. How many people were on your team? On our team,
那个团队大约有 200 人。而我们把他们秒杀了。好的。你们团队有多少人？我们团队，
like I said, less than a dozen. So like 10, 11, somewhere right in there. Was this the story that you told in a different episode where like that team got like way fancier offices? Yeah, they had fancy offices and lunches and pool tables. And you guys were like a Skunkworks project.
就像我说的，不到一 dozen。大约 10 到 11 人，就在那个范围。这就是你在另一期节目里讲的故事吗？说那个团队得到了豪华得多的办公室？是的，他们有豪华的办公室、午餐和台球桌。而你们就像是一个秘密研发项目。
We were a Skunkworks project. We were the side bet. Yeah, we will link that in the description, folks. If you haven't listened to that episode, this isn't me plugging my own episode this is me plugging an amazing story go link it it'll be the second link after getting involved in val yeah so so on that effort right i kind of got to see like like what a team could do that was kind of all on the same page and directed and moving forward and when when I joined the Photoshop team, I think I was like the sixth person to work on Photoshop. And at the time I joined the team, I was one of four.
我们就是一个秘密研发项目。我们是备选方案。是的，各位，我们会在描述中附上链接。如果你还没听过那期节目，这不是我在为自己的节目打广告，而是在推荐一个精彩的故事，去点击它吧，它将是继参与 Val 之后的第二个链接。所以在那次努力中，我有点见识到了一个目标高度一致、方向明确且不断向前的团队能做到什么。当我加入 Photoshop 团队时，我想我是第六个参与 Photoshop 开发的人。而在我加入团队时，我是四个中的一个。
I think that's right. I might be off by one or two, somewhere in there. It's 30 years, so forgive my neurons. But that, you know, if you think about what Photoshop accomplished, and now it seems like, well, Photoshop is just a verb. People don't realize, at the time I left Apple, which was a
我想是的。我可能会记错一两个，大概就在那个范围。已经 30 年了，请原谅我的神经元。但是，想想 Photoshop 所取得的成就，现在看起来，嗯，Photoshop 已经变成了一个动词。人们没有意识到，在我离开苹果时——那是一个
big established company, to go work for Adobe, which nobody heard of because their number one product was PostScript, which was embedded in printers. And even my parents, I was in my early 20s. So my parents were concerned about my career decisions. And they're like, wait, you're leaving Apple to go to this company called Adobe.
大型成熟公司，去为 Adobe 工作——当时没人听说过这家公司，因为他们的头号产品是嵌入在打印机中的 PostScript。甚至我的父母，我当时二十出头，所以我的父母对我的职业决定感到担忧。他们说，等等，你要离开苹果去这家叫 Adobe 的公司？
And you're going to work on a product that's about editing photos on a computer. How do you get a photo into a computer there were no digital cameras why did you go why did i go so two reasons so one is apple like i always say i worked at apple between jobs right so i like joined apple right after steve jobs left and i left Apple before Steve Jobs came back. So I worked at Apple between jobs. So when I started at Apple, Scully was in control and things were going reasonably well. And when I left Apple,
而且你要去做一个关于在电脑上编辑照片的产品。你怎么能把照片弄进电脑里呢？那时根本没有数码相机。你为什么要去？我为什么要去？两个原因。一是苹果，就像我常说的，我在两份工作之间曾在苹果工作，对吧？我加入苹果是在史蒂夫·乔布斯离开后不久，我离开苹果是在史蒂夫·乔布斯回来之前。所以我是在两份工作之间在苹果工作。所以当我开始在苹果工作时，斯卡利掌权，事情进展得相当顺利。而当我离开苹果时，
Spindler had taken over and the management was mostly out of deck and it was an absolute nightmare. What do you mean out of deck? Deck, the company deck computers okay so uh uh i will will tell a story i'll do this without saying names since it's since it's on a podcast also feel free to say names i don't think we have any listeners is that right brian
斯潘德勒接管了，管理层大部分来自 DEC，这简直是一场噩梦。你说的来自 DEC 是什么意思？DEC，那家 DEC 计算机公司。好的。所以……我讲个故事，我就不点名了，既然这是在播客上。你想说名字也可以，我觉得我们没什么听众，对吧，布莱斯？
yeah yeah yeah the one to close your ears. What are they going to do at this point? What are they going to do? So I worked on the transition from 68K to PowerPC, which was very successful. We were the Skunk Works project. Six months before we shipped, we put out a prototype, and we were in success-failure mode, which meant we put out this prototype and our we were in success failure mode which went we put out this prototype we shipped it to a small number of big customers and those customers said this is amazing we're canceling all of our orders for 68k max sign us up for these and apple was like we don't even know if we're going to ship this yet.
对，对，对。把耳朵捂上。他们现在能把我们怎么样？他们能怎么样？所以我参与了从 68K 到 PowerPC 的过渡，非常成功。我们是秘密研发项目。在我们发布前六个月，我们推出了一个原型，我们处于“成败模式”，这意味着我们推出了这个原型，我们把它交付给少数几个大客户，那些客户说这太棒了，我们要取消所有 68K Mac 的订单，快给我们签这些吧。而苹果却说，我们甚至不知道我们是否会发布这个。
And now if we don't, we're dead. Right. And so, so not only do we have to ship this, we have to ship a complete line of this computer of which we were going to ship one model. Now we're going to ship three models. And, and so, so it was this huge, huge scramble. And the team that did this, we had made a conscious decision early on. Apple was working on a new kernel for their operating system and this new version of the OS, which was known as V1. And we said, we don't think V1 will be there in time for us to ship power pc so we created
而现在如果我们不发布，我们就死定了。没错。所以，我们不仅必须发布这个，我们还必须发布这个电脑的完整系列——原本我们只打算发布一种型号。现在我们要发布三种型号。所以，这是一场非常非常巨大的争抢。做这件事的团队，我们在早期就做出了一个有意识的决定。苹果正在为其操作系统和这个被称为 V1 的新版操作系统开发一个新内核，我们说，我们不认为 V1 能按时准备好让我们发布 PowerPC，所以我们创建了
something we called v0 okay and we said you know we're gonna do this on our own without you guys a baby step get us there v0 so we shipped v0 power pc and then our team got together and we said you know we still don't think we can make the leap from v0 to v1 so we proposed a project called alberto which was v05 right so if you are familiar with a hair product there was a hair product once upon a time called alberto v05 so this was version 0.5 um so we proposed this and and management at that time said absolutely not everybody has to get on board for v1 and we started bleeding talent because if you don't believe in a product you're not going to work on it and you're going to leave and so so it was bad. We were drawing tombstones on the whiteboards in the hallway and writing names on them of the engineers who left. And so our, uh, our VP
一个我们称为 v0 的东西。好吧。我们说，你知道的，我们要靠自己来做这个，不用你们，这是一小步，能让我们到达那里，v0。所以我们发布了 v0 PowerPC，然后我们团队聚在一起说，你知道的，我们仍然认为我们无法实现从 v0 到 V1 的跨越，所以我们提议了一个名为 Alberto 的项目，也就是 v0.5，对吧？如果你熟悉某种美发产品，曾经有一款美发产品叫 Alberto V0.5，所以这就是 0.5 版本。嗯，所以我们提出了这个，而当时的管理层说绝对不行，每个人都必须加入 V1 的阵营。于是我们开始流失人才，因为如果你不相信一个产品，你就不会为它工作，你就会离开。所以，情况很糟糕。我们在走廊的白板上画墓碑，并在上面写下离开的工程师的名字。所以我们的，呃，副总裁
has an all hands meeting and it's a traditional all-hands meeting, everybody in an auditorium, and it's like, oh, rah, rah, rah, you know, we need to do this. Oh, but by the way, everybody tighten your belt because in the next quarter it could suck, so, you know, there will be no budget, which is every all-hands meeting
召开了一场全员大会，这是一个传统的老式全员大会，所有人都在礼堂里，就像是，噢，加油加油加油，你知道的，我们需要这样做。噢，顺便说一句，大家都要勒紧裤腰带，因为下一个季度可能会很糟，所以，你知道的，不会有预算——这可以说是如果你在一家公司待了一段时间就会经历的每一次全员大会。
if you've been in the company for a period of time. But one of the engineers raises their hand at a Q&A session at the end and says, so we're losing all these really good people. What do we do about it? And the VP in charge said, I am so sick and tired of all you engineers complaining and people quitting and thinking that that has any relevance to our business whatsoever. You want to see what kind of hole you will leave when you leave this company, put your hand in a bucket of water and pull it back out and look in the bucket. That's the hole you will leave when you exit. This company receives thousands of resumes every single day.
但在最后的问答环节，其中一位工程师举手说，我们正在失去所有这些真正优秀的人才。我们该怎么办？负责的副总裁说，我真是受够了你们所有工程师的抱怨、辞职，还以为这跟我们的业务有半毛钱关系。你想看看当你离开这家公司时会留下什么样的空缺吗？把手伸进一桶水里，然后再抽出来，看看桶里。这就是你离开时留下的空缺。这家公司每天都会收到成千上万份简历。
You are replaceable. And the lead on New Colonel walked up to this EP and handed him his badge and walked out the door. Unsurprisingly. Unsurprisingly unsurprisingly and so i was like i'm done i didn't hand in my badge uh but i had a number of headhunters who had called me and so i called them back and said so what do you have? And one of the headhunters said, you know, there's this position at this company called Adobe. They're pretty small. Very tied with Apple, because if you know the history, it's like, you know, John Warnock and Chuck Getzke had done PostScript at Xerox PARC.
你是可替代的。而新内核项目的负责人走到这位副总裁面前，把胸牌交给他，然后走出了大门。毫不意外。毫不意外，毫不意外。所以我当时想，我受够了。我没有交出胸牌，呃，但我接到过一些猎头的电话，所以我给他们回了电话，说，你们有什么机会？其中一个猎头说，你知道，这家叫 Adobe 的公司有一个职位。他们规模挺小。与苹果关系很密切，如果你了解历史的话，你知道的，约翰·沃诺克和查克·格施克曾在施乐帕克研究中心做过 PostScript。
And they tried to pitch it inside of Xerox PARC. And Xerox PARC was like, we don't know what, you know, we're in the business of making copiers. What do printers have to do with copiers? Right. So they let John and Chuck go with the tech and John and Chuck started Adobe and and took PostScript and PostScript would have failed, except they managed to sell it to Steve Jobs and produce the LaserWriter. And that was just before I had joined Apple. And so Adobe was known to me and known to Apple, certainly, but not broadly known in the industry, right? I mean, you create the operating system for a printer that Apple sells. Okay.
他们试图在施乐帕克内部推销它，而施乐帕克却说，我们不知道，你知道的，我们的业务是制造复印机。打印机跟复印机有什么关系？对吧。所以他们让约翰和查克带着技术离开了，约翰和查克创立了 Adobe，拿走了 PostScript。如果不是他们设法把它卖给史蒂夫·乔布斯并生产了 LaserWriter，PostScript 本来会失败的。那正是我加入苹果之前不久。所以 Adobe 是我所知道的，苹果当然也知道，但在行业内并不广为人知，对吧？我的意思是，你为苹果销售的打印机创建操作系统。好吧。
How many employees were at Adobe when you joined? How many employees were at Adobe when you joined? Good question. So my employee number is 1469, which means it was less than that. Okay. I heard from one of our HR people that there was a block of 800 employee numbers set aside so that they could reassign them for people who came in through acquisitions, who had early hire on dates through the acquired companies because we obey tenure. So that probably puts me in the first 700 people, something like that. You know, six, 700 people. And so at the time when I joined, I don't know, four or 500 people, maybe tops. It was pretty small. We were in, you know,
你加入 Adobe 时，公司有多少员工？你加入 Adobe 时，公司有多少员工？好问题。所以我的员工编号是 1469，这意味着当时比这还少。好吧。我听我们的一位人力资源人员说，当时预留了一批 800 个员工编号，以便他们可以将其重新分配给通过收购进来的员工，这些员工因为通过被收购的公司拥有较早的入职日期——因为我们遵循资历。所以这大概把我排在前 700 人里，诸如此类。你知道的，六、七百人。所以当我加入时，我不知道，四五百人，可能最多也就这样。公司相当小。我们在，嗯，
one of the buildings, which is now the complex and uh rattling around in there frankly you know it was a small enough company that when you got hired on you got to have have lunch with the with the founders so so i had lunch with with john and chuck on on the day i hired in as one does what's that one does, right? It's also notable that they're John and Chuck to you. Yeah. I mean, if you go on my Twitter feed, I posted a recent picture of myself with John. Yeah, these folks, just in case people don't understand the weight, these folks have lengthy Wikipedia pages. We'll link them in the show notes.
其中一栋大楼里，也就是现在的园区，老实说，在里面晃荡。你知道，公司足够小，以至于当你被录用时，你可以和创始人们一起吃午餐。所以，在我入职的那天，我和约翰以及查克一起吃了午餐，就像大家常做的那样。怎么说？就像大家常做的那样，对吧。同样值得注意的是，你直接叫他们约翰和查克。是的。我的意思是，如果你看我的 Twitter 动态，我最近发了一张我和约翰的合影。是的，这些人，以防大家不明白其分量，这些人在维基百科上有很长的词条。我们会在节目笔记中附上链接。
Doesn't Sean have a Wikipedia page? I don't have a Wikipedia page I don't think Sean does, I mean I check every week and so in any case the headhunter said well there's this position at Adobe to work on this product called Photoshop
肖恩没有维基百科词条吗？我没有维基百科词条。我觉得肖恩没有，我的意思是，我每周都查。无论如何，猎头说，嗯，Adobe 有个职位，是去开发一个叫 Photoshop 的产品。
I actually knew of Photoshop it kind of floated around as an interesting product inside of Adobe and so i i had seen it and i went and i talked with the team and it was just this phenomenal team i mean very small team but it was like wow you know i worked with good people at apple. And I talked with this team and it was just like, these are amazing people. And, and then, you know, I actually got in an argument with, with John, John Warnock at the, at this time, the CEO, the CEO, um, uh, about why he was investing at, at, at investing at the time.
其实我知道 Photoshop，它作为 Adobe 内部一个有趣的产品在四处流传。所以我见过它，我去了并和团队谈了谈。这是一个极其优秀的团队，我的意思是团队非常小，但感觉就像是，哇，你知道的，我在苹果和很好的人共事过。我和这个团队交谈后觉得，这些人太棒了。然后，你知道的，其实我和约翰——当时的首席执行官约翰·沃诺克——吵了一架，关于他当时为什么要投资……
So you're looking at 1993, probably mid-93. So the web is brand new, but it's become fairly apparent that HTML is going to win. And Adobe has this thing called PDF and Acrobat that they have maybe 100 engineers engineers on and Photoshop has four. Okay. And, and so John is pouring money into PDF. At that time, that was a significant investment for a relatively small company to be investing. And so the argument I had with John was, what are you doing? HTML wins, you lose. This is good money after bad. It's a sunk cost
所以那是 1993 年，大概是 93 年年中。所以网络还是崭新的，但 HTML 明显将要胜出。而 Adobe 有一个叫做 PDF 和 Acrobat 的东西，他们大概有 100 名工程师在做这个，而 Photoshop 只有 4 个。好吧。所以约翰正在把资金倾注到 PDF 上。在当时，对于一家相对较小的公司来说，这是一笔相当大的投资。所以我跟约翰争论的是，你在干什么？HTML 会赢，你会输。这是在把好钱扔进水沟里。你在这里追逐的是沉没成本
fallacy that you're chasing here. You cannot win. And he was like, no, you are absolutely wrong. He said, you do not looking at all of the governments on of a semi, of manuals, of maintenance manuals for that airplane to the customer, you think that trailer of maintenance manuals for a 747 that a customer is going to look at that in HTML that might be rendered, God knows how, laid out, word wrapped, God knows how, graphics looking like pixelated crap? No. He's like, paper will go away, but it will go away when digital can replace it.
谬误。你不可能赢。而他说，不，你大错特错了。他说，你没有看到世界上所有的政府，所有手册，对于那架飞机的维护手册交付给客户，你认为客户会去查看一车皮的 747 维护手册，而这些手册是用 HTML 渲染的，天知道怎么排版的，怎么自动换行的，图形看起来像像素化的垃圾吗？不。他说，纸张会消失，但它消失的时候，必须是数字技术能够取代它的时候。
And Adobe is set up because Adobe has the interface to the printer through PostScript and PDF is a declarative form of PostScript. We are the only company set up to capture that layout. And he said, he said, I can invest as much money as i can afford into this because we are the only company who will win in this space and and he was absolutely right and and his passion in his articulate argument is part of what sold me and i was like
而 Adobe 做好了准备，因为 Adobe 通过 PostScript 拥有了通往打印机的接口，而 PDF 是 PostScript 的一种声明式形式。我们是唯一一家准备好捕捉这种排版布局的公司。他说，他说，我可以把所有我负担得起的钱投入到这个领域，因为我们将是这个领域唯一赢家。而且他是绝对正确的，他的热情和清晰有力的论点正是说服我的部分原因，当时我想：
i want to go work on this and you know it's like i mentioned my my parents were like how do you get a photo in in into a computer were you arguing with john warlock about this before you had the job yeah yeah so i mean you have to understand like when i got my job at apple i think I might have told this story to you. You told the story where you got in an argument with the interviewer and you thought you lost the job and he called you the next day and it was like, turns out you were correct, sir. Yeah. So, he has a track record for proving his interview was wrong. Was this during your interview with John Warnock?
我想去从事这个工作，你知道的，就像我提到的，我父母当时问：“你怎么能把照片弄进电脑里？”你在拿到工作之前就跟约翰·沃诺克讨论过这个吗？是的，是的。所以你得明白，当我得到苹果的工作时，我想我可能跟你讲过这个故事。你讲过那个故事，你在面试中跟面试官吵了起来，你以为你丢了工作，结果他第二天给你打电话说：“事实证明你是对的，先生。”是的。所以，他有着证明自己面试官是错的记录。这是你在面试约翰·沃诺克时发生的吗？
No, no, I wasn't interviewing with John Warnock, but I was having a conversation with him before I accepted my offer. How did you come to have a conversation with the CEO? Because it's a small company. It's like a startup type of thing. At the time. For folks that are listening now,
不，不，我当时不是在接受约翰·沃诺克的面试，但在我接受 Offer 之前，我和他有过一次谈话。你怎么会有机会跟 CEO 谈话的？因为这是一家小公司。有点像初创公司那种类型。在当时。对于现在正在听节目的朋友们，
Adobe's a big deal. They did well. John was correct. I hesitate to broach a new topic because I really should go make side notes, but I can't not ask. We've never talked about Flash here. But it was obviously a big – I feel like we should table that topic and we'll bring Sean back on, not in 100 episodes, but like in like five or ten. But – because this is honestly heard that before but this is this is amazingly gold like i mean you've told portions of this
Adobe 是一家大公司。他们干得很好。约翰是对的。我有点犹豫要不要开启一个新话题，因为我真的该去写点边角笔记了，但我忍不住要问。我们这里从未聊过 Flash。但这显然是一个重大的——我觉得我们应该把这个话题暂且搁置，我们以后会把肖恩请回来，不是在 100 集之后，而是在比如五集或十集之后。但是——因为这老实说，我以前听过，但这绝对是含金量极高的干货——我的意思是，你以前讲过其中的一部分
stuff before but this is just like we're we're talking to one of like the most senior folks not just in c++ just in the industry and talking about like – like there was an article that I talked about in the Twin Algorithms talk that you were in the midst of getting COVID, which you didn't know at the time but would become to know in a couple days, where Bill Gates got interviewed in some article in 1979. He said, APL was the future. And they described Bill Gates as this guy that was working for this small software company called Microsoft. I interviewed at Microsoft before I went to work at Apple.
内容，但这就好像——我们在和业内，不仅在 C++ 领域，而且在整个行业中最资深的人士之一对话。就像我谈到“孪生算法”演讲时的一篇文章，你当时正处于感染新冠的过程中（你当时并不知道，但几天后就会确诊），比尔·盖茨在 1979 年的一篇文章中接受了采访。他说，APL 是未来。他们把比尔·盖茨描述为一个在一家名为微软的小型软件公司工作的家伙。我在去苹果工作之前曾在微软面试过。
And I didn't talk to Bill. But I talked to some pretty senior people. And they made me an offer. And at the time, my answer was like, your offer is all stock and your stock is already overinflated and there's like no salary. And so, no. And this was like 82. So, how many people are going to buy a personal computer? It's probably not going to be a big thing.
我没跟比尔谈过。但我跟一些相当高级的人聊过。他们给了我一个 Offer。当时我的回答是，你们的 Offer 全是股票，而你们的股票已经估值过高了，而且基本上没有薪水。所以，拒绝。这大概是 82 年。所以，有多少人会买个人电脑？这大概不会成为什么大趋势吧。
Yeah, exactly. Exactly. So, you know, I chalk that up as like career mistakes. My wife had a relative who accepted a position at Microsoft around the same time I turned them down and retired like three years later and lived in Hawaii. Was that the hyper server? That was a different person. No, no, no. So, yeah. So, no.
没错，没错。所以，你知道的，我把这归咎为职业生涯中的失误。我妻子有个亲戚在我拒绝微软前后接受了那里的职位，大约三年后就退休了，住在夏威夷。那是 Hyper-V 服务器的那位吗？那是另一个人。不，不，不。所以，是的。所以，不。
Somebody who I worked with on the PowerPC project, Eric Trout, he did the dynamic recompiling emulator for PowerPC at Apple. And then he did something called Virtual PC. And he did Virtual PlayStation at Connectix. And I think he might have been involved in Speed Doubler. That might have been Yark Brown. He was also the person responsible for Gmail. So that was at Connectix. And then he went to Microsoft and did the Hypervisor. Hypervisor, yeah.
和我一起在 PowerPC 项目上工作的人，埃里克·特劳特（Eric Trout），他在苹果公司开发了 PowerPC 的动态重编译模拟器。然后他做了一个叫 Virtual PC 的东西。他在 Connectix 开发了 Virtual PlayStation。我想他可能还参与了 Speed Doubler。那可能是亚克·布朗（Yark Brown）。他也是负责 Gmail 的人。那是连同 Connectix 一起。然后他去了微软开发 Hypervisor。Hypervisor，对。
Yeah. And then, which is Microsoft's virtualization system. So if you run, you know, virtualized Windows instances on servers, or if you're running, you know, Linux under, what is it, Windows? WSL? WSL. That's all Hypervisor-based stuff. Oh, is it, Windows WSL that's all hypervisor based stuff. Oh is it? WSL is built on top of
是的。然后，也就是微软的虚拟化系统。所以如果你在服务器上运行虚拟化的 Windows 实例，或者如果你在运行 Windows 下的 Linux，那是什么来着？WSL？WSL。这些全都是基于 Hypervisor 的东西。哦，是吗，Windows WSL 全都是基于 Hypervisor 的东西。哦，是吗？WSL 是建立在
hypervisor which is what you're calling Eric Trout Yeah, what Eric Trout did Alright, no big deal So yeah, so Eric, who I hired him as an intern from Stanford, it was really Scott Boyd and now he's retired.
Hypervisor 之上的，也就是你所说的埃里克·特劳特做的。是的，埃里克·特劳特做的。好吧，没关系。所以，是的，埃里克，我当时把他当作斯坦福的实习生招进来，其实是斯科特·博伊德（Scott Boyd）招的，现在他退休了。
And you've never – well, we've got to have you on for multiple reasons now to chat about Flash. But also, I don't think on this podcast you have told the story of interviewing Eric Trout. I mean, I don't know if we want to do that now. No, I think we got to. Because Bryce has got to work on the slides. But folks, stay tuned because I've heard this story and it is – it's a lesson in interviewing and it's just a lesson in so much.
而且你从来——好吧，我们现在有很多理由把你请回来聊聊 Flash。而且，我也觉得在这个播客里你还没讲过面试埃里克·特劳特的故事。我的意思是，我不知道我们现在要不要讲。不，我觉得我们必须讲。因为布莱斯还得去搞他的幻灯片。但是各位，请拭目以待，因为我听过这个故事，它——这是一堂关于面试的课，也是一堂关于很多事情的课。
But like – I'm going to make a note of it. I mean I know you know what I'm talking about because you were the person that told me this story. I'm not sure if Bryce has heard it. But we'll save the Eric – probably Eric does not listen to this podcast. Yeah. But maybe you can send it to him if we tell this story because when I listened to that story, I was – oh, it's – I mean, you have so many amazing – I mean, the poor story where Steve Jobs saved you from lawsuits, that takes the cake. But the Eric Trout interview story is also way up there.
但是——我会记下笔记的。我的意思是，我知道你在说什么，因为你就是那个给我讲这个故事的人。我不确定布莱斯有没有听过。不过我们会把埃里克的故事留着——可能埃里克不听这个播客。是的。但如果我们讲了这个故事，也许你可以发给他，因为当我听到那个故事时，我——哦，这——我的意思是，你有太多精彩的故事了——我的意思是，史蒂夫·乔布斯把你从诉讼中救下来的那个悲惨的故事，简直绝了。但埃里克·特劳特的面试故事也是顶级的。
So stay tuned, dear listener. Mr. Parent will be back. Yeah, we haven't had him on for like 150 episodes. Actually, that's not true because we don't even have 150 episodes. We haven't had him on in a while. But folks, we've lined up the queue of topics to talk about. Flash, Eric Trout. And you guys will just wait for you know another year or
所以亲爱的听众朋友们，请拭目以待。帕特先生还会回来的。是的，我们已经有大概 150 集没请他上节目了。其实不对，因为我们甚至都还没有 150 集。我们已经有一段时间没请他来了。不过各位，我们已经排好了要讨论的话题队列。Flash，埃里克·特劳特。你们就等着吧，再过个一两年
two years well they troll me on this podcast until you get to hear these stories but but uh i'll tell them no no it won't it won't be a year we'll bring you on to tell these stories then we'll troll you for a year after we don't have a queue if we've got a queue now we're gonna have a cue. If we've got a cue... Now we're going to have to go fly out and like wine and dine him to make up for this slight... That's true, I mean... We definitely owe Sean like a nice dinner at this point because a good chunk of why
或者两年——好吧，他们在播客上拿我开涮，直到你能听到这些故事。但是——我会讲的。不，不，不会要一年的，我们会把你请来讲这些故事，然后等我们没有节目队列时，再拿你开涮一年。如果我们现在有队列，我们就会有一个队列。如果我们有一个队列……现在我们得飞过去请他吃吃喝喝，来弥补这次的怠慢……确实，我的意思是……我们现在确实欠肖恩一顿丰盛的晚餐，因为很大一部分
people listen to this podcast is because we've had Sean on it. I mean, probably the plateauing of our statistics. He was buying an entire round of drinks last night for the table because he offered to buy me a drink, I think, in compensation for slighting everybody. And that got confused into Bryce's buying a round for the entire table. So it already cost him a bit. Would you like to comment on this, Bryce?
人们听这个播客的原因是因为我们请了肖恩来。我的意思是，这可能支撑了我们数据的平稳。他昨晚为整桌人买了一整轮酒，因为他提出给我买杯酒，我想，作为对怠慢大家的补偿。结果那被误解成了布莱斯要为整桌人买单。所以这已经花了他不少钱了。布莱斯，你想对此发表点评论吗？
You know what? I have a very expensive girlfriend and everything else by comparison is pretty cheap. Let's hope Ramona is not listening. All right. So I don't even know how to wrap this up. I mean we've – I was trying to parse that and it's like, did you just call your girlfriend cheap? No, no, no.
你知道吗？我有一个非常花钱的女友，相比之下其他所有东西都很便宜。希望雷蒙娜（Ramona）没有在听。好吧。所以我甚至不知道该怎么收尾。我的意思是，我们——我刚才在试图理解那句话，就好像，你刚刚说你的女友很便宜？不，不，不。
The exact opposite. If there's one thing Bryce is guilty of, it is not calling his girlfriend cheap. You know, someday she's going to actually come and start listening to these. And I'm just going to be in so much trouble. Connor, you have to do like splice up the Bryce's girlfriend commentary and play it at his wedding. So, you know what's crazy, Sean? While you were saying that, I was literally thinking, you know, he's saying splice up. You know what would be really funny?
恰恰相反。如果说布莱斯有什么罪过的话，那绝不是说他的女友便宜。你知道，总有一天她会真的来听这些节目的，而我会有大麻烦的。康纳，你得把布莱斯关于女友的评论剪辑拼凑起来，在他婚礼上播放。所以，你知道最疯狂的是什么吗，肖恩？就在你刚才说那番话的时候，我脑子里 literally 在想，你知道的，他说要剪辑拼凑。你知道什么会特别搞笑吗？
If I just put together a compilation. Bryce asked me to speak at his wedding. And then I say, you know, I could say some lovely words about Bryce. But I think I'll let him speak for himself. And then just play. I will have to go back and listen to every single episode. But you know what? I'm really good at listening to things at 2.3x times speed.
如果我把这些剪成一个合集。布莱斯让我做他婚礼的致辞嘉宾。然后我说，你知道的，我可以对布莱斯说一些可爱的话。但我想要让他自己为自己说话。然后直接播放录音。我得回过头去听每一集节目。但你知道吗？我非常擅长以 2.3 倍速听音频。
And it would probably take me about a month to get through our whole backlog and find every single episode but you know what i'm really good at listening to things at 2.3 x time speed and it would probably take me about a month to get through our whole backlog and find every single episode so it would be worth it just for that yeah there we go so so i would attend the wedding just to hear that ramona's gonna kill me ramona's gonna kill me Ramona is gonna kill me I hope Ramona never listens all right we'll wrap it there I mean we're gonna have you back on to talk about flash to talk about Eric Trout to talk about I mean I think oh man I I think we said this on the podcast a year ago that the time to be a c++ dev has never been more exciting. The time to be a system programmer. Yeah.
这大概需要花我大约一个月的时间才能听完我们所有的积压节目并找到每一集。但你知道吗？我真的很擅长以 2.3 倍速听音频，这大概需要花我大约一个月的时间才能听完我们所有的积压节目并找到每一集，所以仅仅为了这个就完全值得了。耶，就是这样。所以——我会为了听到这个而去参加婚礼。雷蒙娜会杀了我，雷蒙娜会杀了我，雷蒙娜会杀了我。我希望雷蒙娜永远不要听到。好吧，我们就到这里结束。我的意思是，我们会请你回来聊聊 Flash，聊聊埃里克·特劳特，聊聊——我的意思是，我觉得，天哪，我想我们一年前在播客里就说过，现在做 C++ 开发者从未像现在这样激动人心。做系统程序员的时代亦是如此。
Because – C++ dev works. I mean, it's still – it's a huge community. It's an amazing community. So as much as I, like, criticize C++, the community has only grown over the years. And – Even with the pandemic it's amazing how quickly all the conferences like it's amazing that we are once again at a c++ conference
因为——C++ 开发依然有效。我的意思是，它仍然是一个庞大的社区，一个了不起的社区。所以尽管我批评 C++，但这些年来社区只增不减。而且——即使经历了疫情，所有会议恢复的速度也令人惊叹——我们再次参加 C++ 会议真是太棒了，
and that that this all picked up again and i hope what happened tonight so we got to interview basically three of the other main c++ podcasts and like I don't know if this will be a regular thing at C++ on scene and Jonathan Mueller and some other people and a couple folks yes that we got little anecdotes from but I just put those in there to make life a little harder for you because now you gotta listen through the recording and figure out exactly
这一切又重新开始运作了。我希望今晚发生的事——我们基本上采访了其他三个主要的 C++ 播客，而且——我不知道这会不会成为 C++ on Sea 的常态，还有乔纳森·穆勒（Jonathan Mueller）和其他一些人，以及几位朋友，是的，我们从他们那里得到了一些小轶事，我把这些放进去只是为了让你的生活更艰难一点，因为现在你得听完整段录音并弄清楚到底
who was who. Yeah the fact that you think I don't already listen through the whole recording and edit it just speaks volumes about what you think goes into producing this. But Bryce doesn't listen to this podcast. My favorite thing that we learned tonight is that JF and Chris, for their podcast, they pay somebody to do the post-production for them. We're going to send it over to Sean. Closing notes, closing thoughts.
谁是谁。是的，你觉得我不会已经听完整段录音并进行剪辑，这充分说明了你对制作这个节目所需要付出努力的看法。但布莱斯根本不听这个播客。我们今晚学到的最喜欢的事情是，JF 和克里斯为他们的播客雇了专门的人来做后期制作。我们要把它发给肖恩。结束语，最后的想法。
We're going to have everything in the show notes, but we'll let you close it out. I'm super easy to find. So I'm, you know, at Sean Parent on Twitter or just search for Sean Parent and I think... He has a website. Yeah, I feel sorry for the other Sean Parents on the planet because I usually snag the
我们会在节目笔记中列出所有内容，但我们会让你来做收尾。我非常容易找到。所以我是，你知道的，在 Twitter 上搜索 @SeanParent，或者直接搜索 Sean Parent，我想……他有网站。是的，我为地球上其他叫 Sean Parent 的人感到难过，因为我通常会抢先
names first. You did hear about the internet first, unfortunately, for all those other Sean parents. Yeah. You discovered Adobe when they were a small company, so unfortunately the other Sean's parents have no hope.
注册这些名字。不幸的是，对于所有其他 Sean 的父母来说，你率先了解了互联网。是的。你在 Adobe 还是一家小公司时就发现了它，所以不幸的是，其他 Sean 的父母毫无希望了。
Yeah, so sorry all the other Sean parents. You are out of luck. I own the internet, at least as far as your name is concerned. But yeah, you know, if you're interested thesis idea, we are full of thesis ideas. So, yeah. So, contact us and hit us up and we'll get something going. So, if you're listening to this and you're like, what do I do? Check the show notes. We will have
是的，所以对所有其他 Sean 的父母感到抱歉。你们运气不好。我拥有互联网，至少在你们的名字这方面是这样的。但是，是的，如果你对毕业论文的想法感兴趣，我们充满了毕业论文的想法。所以，是的，联系我们，找我们，我们会把事情搞定。所以，如果你正在听这个，并且在想，我该怎么做？查看节目笔记。我们会有
links to contact Sean, to contact the Val folks, to get involved with Val. It'll all be in the show notes. Anything you want to say before we close out here, Bryce? I really wish I had more time to finish my slides. I mean, this is the beauty of this podcast is that, you know, as much as I criticize Bryce, he could be working on his slides right now. But he understands that this conversation trumps all. So even though we didn't have Sean on for, I don't know, it wasn't 150 episodes, but it was like 50 episodes or something. So once we wrap this up, I i'm gonna tell this amazing story to connor and you're teasing the listener and and we're gonna go get a beer and bryce is not invited because he has to go do his slides so so bryce will never hear this story because we're not
联系肖恩的链接，联系 Val 团队的链接，参与 Val 的链接。都会在节目笔记里。在你离开之前，布莱斯，你还有什么想说的吗？我真的很希望我有更多时间来完成我的幻灯片。我的意思是，这个播客的精妙之处在于，尽管我批评布莱斯，他现在本可以去搞他的幻灯片。但他明白这场对话高于一切。所以尽管我们没有请肖恩来——我不知道，这不是 150 集，而是大约 50 集左右。所以一旦我们结束这个，我要把这个精彩的故事讲给康纳听，而你一直在吊听众的胃口，然后我们要去喝杯啤酒，而布莱斯没有被邀请，因为他得去搞他的幻灯片，所以布莱斯永远不会听到这个故事，因为我们
gonna put it on the next podcast. Yeah. That is amazing, folks. We're going to wrap it there. And this is why, you know, Phil didn't really plug his conference well enough. But this is the reason you come to conferences. They talk about the hallway track. You could be at the Best Western Clifton Hotel outside the Lee's Hall. Lee's Hall. That's where the conference is.
不打算把它放到下一期播客里。是的。太棒了，各位。我们就到这里结束。这就是为什么——嗯，菲尔（Phil）其实没有好好宣传他的会议。但这就是你来参加会议的原因。他们谈论走廊闲谈。你可以住在李斯大厅（Lee's Hall）外面的克利夫顿贝斯特韦斯特酒店。李斯大厅。会议就在那里。
The hotel is right next to it 30 seconds away. It is quite the funky hotel. It is. I mean it's under renovations. My room. I gotta say, I'm I think everybody knows I'm a princess when it comes to my travel arrangements. We do all know that. And actually the princess
酒店就在旁边，30 秒路程。这真是一家挺奇特的酒店。确实。我的意思是它正在装修。我的房间。我得说，我想大家都知道我在旅行安排上是个公主。我们确实都知道这一点。其实“公主”
is the best description I've ever heard of Bryce. This is a good venue. Like, there's some quirks. You don't have all the options that you'd have in a big city. This is a good venue. It's a good location. Yeah, it's been a little bit rainy today.
是我听过的对布莱斯最好的形容。这是一个好场地。有些小瑕疵。你没有在大城市里拥有的所有选择。这是一个好场地。地理位置不错。是的，今天稍微有点下雨。
But, folks, the point is it's not about the venue. It's not about the weather. It's about the fact that if you were at this conference right now, you could be departing from Bryce and joining Sean and I to hear this story that no one else will ever hear on the pod because it's clearly not appropriate to tell on air and we love that for me not for Bryce because he's got to go prepare for a keynote tomorrow morning at 9.15 we'll all be there and by all I mean none of you
但是，各位，重点不在于场地。不在于天气。重点是，如果你现在就在这个会议上，你本可以离开布莱斯，加入肖恩和我，来听这个永远不会在播客上播出的故事，因为这显然不适合在节目中讲述，我们太喜欢这种感觉了，当然是对我而言，而不是对布莱斯，因为他必须去为明天上午 9 点 15 分的主旨演讲做准备，我们都会去，我说的“都”是指你们一个都不会去
you know what that keynote may be at 9.30 alright folks you heard it here first thanks for listening we probably interrupted our Slovenia road trip for three episodes, probably one for the pod and two for Sean. And in three episodes – well, actually one episode from now when I'm saying this because it's the final of the three partitions, we'll be back to the Slovenia road trip. And stay tuned for real-time updates in like September because we have content for like three months now. So, all right.
你知道的，那个主旨演讲也可能是 9 点 30 分。好吧，各位，你们在这里听到了第一手消息。感谢收听。我们可能为了三集节目中断了我们的斯洛文尼亚公路旅行，其中一期是播客，两期是给肖恩的。在三集之后——好吧，其实在我说这话时的一集之后，因为这是三部分的最后一集，我们将回到斯洛文尼亚公路旅行。敬请期待九月份左右的实时更新，因为我们现在有足够三个月的存货内容了。所以，好了。
Good night. Good night, folks. Good night. Be sure to check the show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for anything that we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave comments, thoughts, or questions about today's episode. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity.
晚安。晚安，各位。晚安。请务必查看您播客应用中的节目笔记，或访问 ADSPthepodcast.com，了解我们在今天节目中提到的任何内容，以及一个 GitHub 讨论链接，您可以在那里留下对今天节目的评论、想法或问题。感谢收听。希望您喜欢，祝您有美好的一天。低质量，高产量。
That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是“夹杂着信息 sprinkles 的混乱”。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。